字幕: Maki Sugimoto
校正: Emi Atarashi
最近 自分のことを大切にしてますか？
オーガニックとかビーガンとか
ミニマリズムとか
最近 色々なワードが入ってきて
ライフスタイルっていうのが
選択できるようになってきてます
いまサステイナブルに生きていく
っていう生き方も
課せられてるような感じがしています
私がよく尋ねられるのが
実際に地球にやさしい事って
何したらいいの？
私はいつも逆に
じゃあ あなたは
実際にどれだけ自分に
優しくしてるのって
聞き返すことがあります
過去に大量生産とか
大量消費をかなり促すような
アパレル企業で
働いていたことがあります
その時にすごく大量な
衣類の破棄を目の当たりにしたり
必要以上にトレンドを作ったり
そういうことを見てきて
要は結局すべて最終的に
ゴミになるようなものを
必要以上に作っていたんですね
その時に 何かこれって
気持ち良くないなって思って
憧れて入ったアパレル企業だったけど
実際に見たのって
自分たちが20年30年たった時に
持続していないような
ビジネスだったんですよね
そこからまた新たに
別の企業に移ったんですけど
そこではもう もともとサステイナブルな
取り組みっていうのがたくさん行われていて
私はその中でその当時
巡り合わせた仲間と一緒に
ゼロウェイストというのをテーマに
ごみを根本的に出さない
ワークプレイス職場を
作り上げていこう
という取り組みを
みんなでしたんですね
そこが１つの店舗から始まり
どんどん全国に広まっていって
そのゼロウェイストということが
そこで働く人たちにとって
当たり前のことに
なるようなものになって
それがみんなの
一部になったんですよ
そのときに 本当に必要なものって
すっごい少ないんだね
なんでこんなに余分なものが
世の中にいっぱいあるんだろうね
っていう会話が生まれて
今までそういうことを考えたことも
なかったような人も もちろんいたし
あとはよく聞かれたように何かしたいけど
何をしたらいいかわからない
みたいな人にとって
あ これが何か
してるってことなんだ
というふうに気づく
きっかけになったんです
１つの店舗でその時に出る
ゴミの量っていうのが
圧倒的に減ったんですよね
例えば １日でごみ袋３袋分ぐらい
出てたようなものが
半年でごみ袋２つ分とか
そういう凄い もう
目に見えて明らかに
大きいチェンジとなって
成果が出たので
でもそれって誰も苦しんでないし
誰も苦労してないんですよ
自然と心掛けていたら
できてたことだから
なんかサステイナブルな
ことをしなきゃとか
地球に良いことしなきゃって
すごい大きな使命感を持って
自分の中でルールを決めてしまったり
これをやらなきゃいけない
こうしなきゃいけないって
責めていくと ちょっと
詰まっちゃって できないけど
何かそれこそ
ライフスタイルの一部として
自分の選択肢の１つとして
やっていくと
自然とできちゃうので
何も苦しいことはないんですね
じゃあ具体的に何を
私何ができるかな
もちろんペットボトルを
なるべく買わないようにするとか
ファストファッションを
買わないように心がけるとか
何かを買わないように
心がけるっていうのは
すごく簡単なことで
それは誰にでもできることなんです
だけど 毎日使っているものとか
買い慣れてるものをいきなり
やめるということでもなく
逆にじゃあ そういう
ものの代わりに
これサステイナブルって書いてあるから
これ買ってみようかなとか
エコって書いてあるからこれ使ってみよう
という考えも違うんですよ
始まりはそこじゃなくて良くて
始まりはいま自分が置かれてる
身がどういう状況か
自分が本当に必要な
ものって何だろう
自分にとって本当に
心地良いものとか
心が躍るようなことって
何だろうって考えて
自分の中をまず見つめることで
すごくいろんなことが見えてきます
じゃあどこで買い物すればいいのとか
すごく聞かれたりもするんですけど
自分の住んでいる地域の
一番近いところで作られてるものとか
あとは “私が作りました”
作った人の顔が見えるところとか
そういった所で地域と
つながっていくと
自然と地産地消もそうですし
自分の身の回りだけで
必要なものがそろえられる
ということに気づくんですよ
わざわざ週１回30分
１時間かけてドライブして
超大型スーパーに
行ってますとか
もちろんそのライフスタイルがあって
家族の状況とかも違うので
必ずしも これじゃなきゃ
だめっていうのはないんですけど
身の回りでコトを済ますことで
より少なく よりいいものを
自分で厳選することが
実はできるんです
だからどこで買い物を
ここで絶対買い物した方が
いいです ではなくて
自分の住んでいる地域で
何があるかなって
改めて探してみるのは
すごくいいかなと思います
サステイナブルってすごく
トピックも大きいし
環境問題っていうのはもちろん
すごく深刻であって
もういま１分１秒を争う
事態なんですよね
私たち１人１人が本当に
意識して行動しないと
もう手遅れになるのも間近だし
本当に20年30年
近い将来の話になってくるので
かなり問題は重要です
でも だからって
そこにすべて身を削って
こう自分を責めながら
何かをするのではなくて
やっぱり楽しまなきゃいけない
要素もあるんですよ
何かそれこそちょっと何か
心が躍るような
ウキウキするような気持ちに
なれるのもすごく大事だし
女性であったり 男性でもそうですけど
オシャレなもの かわいいものとか
それらに囲まれることも
すごく大事だと思うんですね
それも結局 自分が幸せかどうか
自分が心地いいかどうかだから
そういう要素も絶対に大事だし
あんまりこう
自分でこうしなきゃ
みたいな枠にはまらずに
何が心地いいかっていうのを
追求していくのがいいと思います
だってこの10年で もしかしたら
私たちの行動次第で
もっともっと環境は
悪化していくかもしれないし
当たり前のように毎日の食材を
調達することもできないかもしれない
いま現に日本は恵まれてるかもしれないけど
世界中のいろんなところで
いろんなことが起きてて
明日生きるか死ぬか みたいな状況に
置かれてる人がたくさんいますよね
経済状況もそうだけど
もちろん戦争もそうだし
あとは環境変化による災害とか
そういったものでまともに
生きられない人が たくさんいる
明日は我が身なんですよ
だから10年後
もしこれを聞いてるんだったら
それはもしかしたら
今この10年前の私たちが
正しい選択をしてたからかもしれないし
その正しい選択が何かっていう
答えは１つじゃないけど
結局 最終的に自分にとっていいもの
環境にとっていいもの
物だけじゃなくて
アクションとか仕事とか
いろんなことがすべて繋がって
10年後20年後さらに
この映像が残ってたら
正しい選択をしたなって
多分思えると思います
ひとつのことに ちょっとこだわってると
なかなか視野が狭く
なりがちなんだけど
そうじゃなくて結局ちょっと
一歩ステップバックして
大きいピクチャーを見ると
いろんなことがつながってて
その自分の悩みとか
もしくはちょっと体を壊して
病気をしてる人とかも
もちろんいるし
なにか家族との問題が
ある人もいるし
いろんな問題の中の１つに
環境問題っていうのがあって
ただそこだけは確実に
私たち全員が直面している問題
それをこう
それに対して戦うじゃないけど
取り組み方っていうのは多分
いろいろあると思って
私は最終的に何かいろんな
試行錯誤しながら
結局 自分に良いことしてると
他にも優しくなれるな
イコール環境に優しいことっていうのを
考える余裕が出てくる
だから 今 どうしようかな
何したらいいかなって
悩んでたりとかしたら
もしかしたら
まず最初にできることって
自分が辛いなって思ってることとか
我慢してることを
手放してみるっていうのが
ちょっと気持ちが軽くなって
次の新しいことに行くきっかけに
なれるかもしれないです
いや でも本当に簡単なことなんですよ
なんでみんな できないんだろう
って思うよね
本当に人って余裕ないよね
だから 私もそうだけど
ライフスタイルっていうのは
物で成り立ってるわけじゃなくて
あなた自身のマインドで
成り立ってるんだよっていうのを
いつも伝えていて
考え方次第で全てを
変えていけることができて
私たちの考えがあるから
社会も動くし 世界も動くし
そこで結局 地球がどんどん
良くなっていければいいなっていうのが
一番伝えたいことです
これをきっかけにサステイナブル
っていうのを重く考えずに
ちょっと自分にいいことを
今日してみようかなとか
そういうところから
始められて
それがいずれ
物にとらわれないことの自由さとか
所有するものが
目に見えるものじゃなくて
そうじゃないもの以外を
自分で持っているって豊かさに
気づいた時に
１人１人のサステイナブルの
本当のライフジャーニー
っていうのが始まるんですよ
それでそれがすごく価値のある
持続可能な人生に
なっていくと思います
私のモットーが
「所有は少なく もっと生きよう」
物に執着せずに
もっと生きろっていうことなんです
［所有は少なく もっと生きよう］